so hello everybody i'm really excited to
be here with uh with deacon enoch again
enoch is of course uh an ethiopian
christian tawedo christian he also has a
youtube channel uh called the philosophy
of art and science so you can look that
up and find him he's also on the thesis
network where he is doing several things
with different uh different types of
orthodox uh discussions and everything
so i'm really excited to have him on
because we're going to uh to talk you
know there people can't get enough of
talking about ethiopia and uh and the
particulars of their traditions and so
we're gonna look go into that together
this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Applause]
thank you so much jonathan for having me
on the program i'm really happy you know
it's funny because when i noted i
mentioned that on the podcast i said
uh you know i kind of said for people to
to reach out if they wanted to i got so
many messages suggesting you and then i
realized that even that before that i
actually got messages from people
suggesting you like the first time the
first moment we did the first video i
had people talking about you but i get
so many messages that sometimes it just
becomes like noise that i don't i can't
totally pay attention to but then when i
after i asked that then i remembered i
said i think i think many people have
been suggesting him for a long time it's
so funny that you said that because i've
gotten a few people to comment
and you know they think if i just reach
out that they will it'll happen but the
podcasting world for people to to know
behind the curtain doesn't always work
like that especially when you have a
large following the way that that you've
said and i've actually been following
your work for years and i know you were
surprised that i had already known you
from your breaking down of kanye as the
fool to watch out for the stuff you've
done with jordan peterson and father
andrew as well like i i had been
following your work and i've been
sharing your artwork on twitter whenever
you you would post you know the the
cosmos and and everything like that so
it's really great and then when richard
reached out to me it was funny because
richard and i were already facebook
friends but he's kind of pseudonymous
anonymous i didn't realize how many
facebook friends i had him and i were
already friends on facebook that's funny
yeah so a nice confluence of things kind
of coming together so maybe tell us a
little bit about yourself i know you
live in the u.s uh maybe tell us a
little bit about your your involvement
in the church and kind of the way that
you see it also as an american ethiopian
american
yeah so i love the anglo-saxon saying
but for the grace of god go i and it's
very true
my service my ministry is sometimes
inexplicable to people outside of you
know the holy ghost or anything to that
effect
um i was
i am born and raised in los angeles
california and i am the son of two
immigrants who came to america one year
before the fall of emperor hilas allahis
regime
which if you go on the conservative
estimate was about a 700 year uh
orthodox christian monarchy and
depending on if you want to say it's
continuous or not some people like to
throw the number 3000 year regime
including in the early days pagan but
beginning in the 300s a.d
orthodox christian kingdom so according
to their official records it's one
lineage all the way back to solomon
basically
that that's right and there are a lot of
people you know depending on if you're
uh a member of the symbolic world or if
you're one of the academic historians
how you want to count it but the most
conservative estimate would bring it
back to 1270 a.d that's which is which
is really even if it's 700 years it
might still be the oldest like uh
maybe except for like china like you
know how they had these super long uh
dynasties or japan or something it's
probably one of the oldest dynasties in
the world
it's super old and i didn't realize a
lot of these things until i was an adult
because you know part of it is is trauma
that people in my parents generation
faced and part of it is things that they
did but basically their generation was
involved with marxist leninism some of
them would like to claim that all they
wanted was feudal reform and and i
mentioned this not delve to delve too
much into politics because it's so much
of what makes up my being and where i am
and so
ethiopia's pivotal moment was 1974 when
communism took over and all the former
institutions were were shattered and it
wasn't that it happened in a day it was
kind of a long process of of decades
that also involved the west and not just
russia yeah and um interestingly enough
we had ties with the tsarist russia too
so it's funny that we had later ties
with with communist russia and so the
the elites were a number of them were
executed by the communist regime and
another of them were drained from the
country during during a time period of
like 20 to 30 years and so my parents
left right before all of that took off
and then a lot of their friends were in
the midst of that so i grew up in a
milieu of all of these people who were
ethiopian elites drained from the
country and then who were living abroad
and just trying to
focus and and you know assimilate to
american society so i assimilated very
well both of my parents were trained in
british schools so you know they knew
english before they came to this country
but they also were very strict about me
learning the amharic language which is
the official language of of ethiopia
and for me i was raised really nominally
christian i was baptized i went to all
the high holidays but i was never a
sunday christian
and
i went to various you know schools i
went to a lutheran middle school i went
to a church of christ which is part of
the revivalist american tradition 1800s
college which made me confront the idea
of christ and so in adulthood i came to
the church start off pouring holy water
they realized i spoke on heart so they
made me sing even though i couldn't
really sing so i became a chanter then
they said oh he's uh he knows how to
teach so they made me teach in english
then they pre-started having me sub for
them teaching in amharic at funerals and
other services and then they said you
know it's really weird that we have this
unordained guy that would call mr enoch
and we can't just call him mr enoch so
let's uh throw this deacon title on him
so i have a little bit of a windy path
and a different path you know most
people in the ethiopian church become
deacons between the ages of like 8 and
13. i became it at the canonical age in
our tradition of 25. so it's uh it's
been about five six years and uh it's
it's been a great train and i i
predominantly focus on on scripture and
liturgy but i have a little bit of uh
competency and knowledge of some other
parts of the church as well
so are there formal trainings or is it
all kind of imbibed into like within the
church like do you take have you taken
classes or is it just this
so in ethiopia there are formal schools
there's the traditional school it's
called abnet which actually
means fatherhood which is great
and it's uh you know it's if you think
about it from the educational models in
the united states it would drive you
know educators here insane because what
they do is you know i'll give you one
example the administrator of my church
who's a monk he's a hyrule monk
he left his house at age 10
and he decided wherever he wanted to go
throughout the whole country
and you have one school of poetry you
have one school of the main liturgy
which is the eucharistic liturgy you
have another school which is the
non-eucharistic liturgy and then you
have another
school dedicated to scripture and
patristics and he went to and fro to
whatever school he wanted without anyone
watching him
and he was a deacon at age 10 at 22 he
decides to be a monk and basically you
know he got all of his church education
between 10 and 22
and you can say it's like a hyper
humanities program with you know
indigenous phds but you know he he
couldn't do multiplication you know
because they don't study even the basics
of arithmetic all they focus on are
church teachings
it's amazing and so there are different
schools so it's like you go to one
school to learn one aspect again the one
that really fascinated me was poetry
poetry yeah so it's called kenny uh
which
is uh which is the liturgical language
and the the language of the right kenny
means to submit and so the idea is you
create poetry that submits to the lord
and glorifies him and then also the
saints through whom which he is
glorified and there are a million
different categories i don't even know
them all but the two main ones the two
most important because they have to do
with communion time
one is called kibriyti which means
she is honorable
referring to the time which is the
moment in which the communion descends
and is being distributed to the people
and that is poetry that is reserved
exclusively about christ and
christological themes and then you have
the anamoger
which is like the something like the um
i don't know the full translation but
something like the the rising incense
where you're allowed to speak of the
cloud of witnesses of all the saints to
glorify god which is after the beginning
poetry is so people study the poetry in
advance they're not allowed to write it
down they're supposed to memorize it and
then they perform it in the church one
time and then you know they move on from
there that's it
one time one time so there's original g
is poetry being created by tens of
thousands of clergy
every day that is amazing whenever
people tell me this is a dead language i
say hogwash
but that is astounding and so they
perform it during the liturgy they
perform it every sunday during the
liturgy at um you know there are three
different types of parishes let's say
small medium and large every medium and
large definitely every large parish will
do it if it's a basic church where
someone's not trained in the poetry
where all they do is the main function
of the liturgy they wouldn't perform it
there for example at my church we don't
have a poetry master we have a couple
priests who studied it a little bit so
we do it only on the high holidays but
they'll have to take them longer to
prepare like they'll prepare their poem
and everything exactly but there's a
master at it at a parish for example
that a friend of mine attends in san
diego they do it every sunday and which
is the tradition in ethiopia
that's astounding and so are there some
poems that are so that have been kind of
so intense that people remember them
let's say
yes and they're written down there's um
there's a
different books like what they'll say
freilig allent which means the the fruit
of the sages or yelikaantkani which is
the poetry of the sages and they'll
write them down in in famous books
actually the administrator of my church
who i mentioned to you earlier he's uh
unique in that he learned
this poetry although he didn't master it
he learned this poetry from a nun named
mahoy gallanish and she herself was the
student of her father who was a master
it's rare for women to to enter these
fields especially at the highest level
especially to become a master and then
to be teaching you know all the boys
coming up in in the faith but you know
there's one famous one where i i'm gonna
butcher it
people could go to my channel where a
friend of mine who studied for about a
year to two years he performed it on my
on my channel but it's it's something to
affect where speaking about the digits
of of christ there are a few different
layers to the poetry
one of the layers is that it has to hit
a certain rhythm because it's not just
read aloud but it's it's poetry that's
sung it's chanted basically chanted so
it has to meet the the rhythm and the
melody of the chanting and then it has
to have a basic meaning known as the wax
and then underneath the wax is the gold
which is supposed to be the the
christological meaning or whatever other
religious meaning and so there's there's
a saying about how the thumb is greater
than the other fingers and how both
uh jesus and nicodemus were rabbis but
they weren't the same type of rabbi you
know jesus was the thumb and
nicodemus was one of the other digits so
this the same way in which the thumb
guides the the other fingers separating
us from other creatures jesus is
separated from nicodemus that's like one
example of something they would do and
they would you know they would yell it
one person would yell it in
and then the person would other person
would stand in front of them and would
sing it before the congregation oh okay
so this the person performing will have
a chanter will then redo it will
actually sing it yes and usually the
person who is speaking it is usually
more learned than the person who's just
singing it because the the fundamental
basic levels are just repeating like you
said famous poems of of the sages or of
the scholars
and then singing it singing these famous
lines whereas the actual construction of
the original poetry will take a while
yeah that's amazing that's astounding i
mean i'm sure there's so many things
like that that that people don't know
about that are just like an entire
tradition of poetry that's recited one
time in church we have nothing like that
i mean one of the things people complain
about in the
the orthodox church in the the greek
russian church is the stifling a little
bit of the stifling of the of
hymnography where we feel like there
isn't a lot of room for modern day poets
or modern day people to kind of enter
into the tradition and participate in
this this pattern of glorification you
know and rising up the saints and rising
up god but you but these
your tradition seems to have this
balance of you know the normal liturgy
but then at each liturgy there is a
moment where but and it's not just like
kind of
i don't want to be insulting but it's
not like just like improvised hands in
the air you know screaming a thing it's
an actual form that has pattern and
everybody recognizes as as this poetry
tradition it's just astounding to me
yeah and they're recognized usually as
the most intelligent people
and usually they will not let you study
scripture or patristics unless you've
spent one to two years in the poetry
school like that's a requirement at many
of the scripture and patristic schools
yeah you wish they had that here all
those bible scholars if they could just
study poetry we'd get a lot less like a
lot of lot less his critical historical
nonsense that we get that we get now so
i have a big question for you this is my
big question because i'll be honest with
you i think that both richard and i when
we did the three episodes on ethiopia we
were obviously a little nervous because
we're talking about something which in a
way is very far from us
and we're also talking about how
when we look at ethiopia and tradition
the christian traditions and because
it's related to the ark and all of that
you've learned you've heard them we talk
about
about the stories and everything it's
kind of this extremes going into
extremes and so
my my question from the beginning was
how would someone who lives in the
church and worshipped in the church
would would how would they interpret the
way that we we saw it
well i will tell you i'm i'm biased in a
little bit but i'll tell you all the
sides of it and my bias is that while i
am firmly rooted in the church and you
know i mean my my father's side of the
family are basically levites you know
several generations of of clergy even
though it skipped his generation
um i i grew up in the west yeah so
i have you know a native fluency in the
amharic language
intermediate knowledge of goods and i've
been serving in the church over a decade
however there are still some parts of me
which are western so one example i can
give you
is that
any sort of
deep conversation about the ark
begins to make ethiopian orthodox
nervous
it's almost as if the mystery is
cheapened whenever you talk about it and
so you'll see i think another
aspect that's unique about ethiopia
everyone has kind of
like holy drapes or holy clothing and
covers that you put on items the
ethiopian church almost to the point of
like secrecy or gnosticism hides
everything uh one thing i could tell is
we're in communion with the cops and the
cops have their clergy
commune and finish the rest of communion
in front of the entire audience
uh without getting too specific to freak
out the ethiopians i'll say the
ethiopians don't do that and yet we're
in communion so
there's something hidden there where
nobody sees the clergy taking communion
actually in our tradition and it's like
the arc there's very few things
spoken about it my bishop actually was
the bishop of southern california
beginning in the 90s began preaching
explicitly telling people what's
physically written on all of the tablets
and a lot of people freaked out but it's
it's absolutely normal in terms of
the elites who have always known this
information it's just this balance of is
this information only for the elites or
you know are we on youtube now and
hundreds of thousands of people will be
hearing about it and talking about it
but i think both of you were extremely
respectful um i told you before we kind
of hopped on i have two kind of minor
maybe three minor points of contention
but overwhelmingly you were doing it
from a place of love and i think both of
you were very well researched the idea
on a serious note of the extreme edge
and the inclusion of the
of the outsider i mean the gentile par
excellence it's like it's not just a
gentile but a dark-skinned gentile like
that's what ethiopia is always in
scripture and and the arc language that
you all used as the container i think
was i think it's going to be very
informative for very uh for the
english-speaking ethiopian world for the
diaspora ethiopian orthodox i think it's
going to be very enlightening and
illumining uh
as well like the
the whole monster on the lake story that
you told the fact that you asked the
guide and he was reluctant and then he
talked about that i was crying on my way
to work while i was listening to that
episode because it's it's so true
that some of the more secular tour
guides wouldn't want to talk about that
because they think something like that
is embarrassing but a sabbath honoring
monster is definitely noteworthy yeah
it's definitely it was to me it was like
i felt like i was in a like i was in a
fairy tale i was happy about it i was
like i feel like i'm in a world of of
magic you know i mean there are so many
when i was in ethiopia there were so
many kind of magical moments my my guy
knew the old guardian of the ark you
know because they're they're they're the
one that was actually serving and then
there was the one who was kind of
retired but couldn't leave the
the precinct and so he said you know
would you want uh to meet him
and i was like yeah of course i want to
meet him like i can't even ask that so
he's like okay he's like i just want to
tell you we'll go there you know i'll
knock on the door i'll say if he wants
to meet you um
but he said don't ask him about the art
because he's sick of hearing about that
like just don't ask him about that uh
and so i'm like okay cool so we go there
he goes down you know it's like another
door on the side down at the bottom of
the building and he knocks and he talks
to the guy and then i see him come out
this old man you know covered in his in
his cloth
and i i mean i don't know what to do i
just kind of smile and say hello and and
just kind of kind of bow a little bit
and then he asked me he says is there
something you want me to bless
and i was like oh and so i realized i
remembered that i had brought one of my
very early carved icons like when i was
in africa i was living in kenya i carved
this little icon so i'm like yeah i have
this icon in my bag so i go in my bag i
take out my icon so imagine like i have
one of my very first icons that i carve
i hand it to him he looks at it
and my guide was interpreting for me and
he says
oh it's modern
like only an ethiopian man could look at
one of my icons and say like oh it's a
it's a it's very modern like it's very
you know it's not very traditional yeah
so he he so he looks at it and he says
words that i can't understand and he
spits on it several times and it spits
and says and says the words and gave it
back to me and so i still have it
obviously i'm going to keep it forever
i'm never going to get rid of that icon
it was one of those amazing yeah this is
just these kind of amazing magical
moments that i had in ethiopia um
so have you been to ethiopia do you have
you traveled
yes i've been i don't know exactly how
many times but something like 12 times
if you add them all up it'll it'll
probably be two years but it's
one month three weeks two months at a
time
throughout my childhood it's been a
decade since i've been but throughout my
childhood i went every other year and
that's i think what strengthened my my
ties to
to ethiopia one of the things i left out
of my short bio in the beginning is that
with the fall of the regime in ethiopia
the last vestige of this 3000 year
dynasty is the ethiopian orthodox church
it is the only thing that is still
standing that preserves that and so my
parents weren't very outwardly pious i
would say they were inwardly pious in
the way you know
jesus often would recommend throughout
for example the gospel of matthew the
sort of sermon on the mount life of not
doing things for people but doing things
behind closed doors
and like i said they kept the structure
of it for me but they never imposed it
upon me and it was really a love of
ethiopia just being a proud ethiopian
that made me assess the situation and
realize that
the the strongest institute of ethiopia
is the ethiopian orthodox church so
going back home
uh i mean you see that like i didn't
grow up in the church so i remember one
of my earliest memories as being
in ethiopia at my grandparents house
both of whom lived on the same street my
grandparents had passed away the the
fathers but the mothers were there
and
the priests would come to your house
randomly you'd feed them and you know
they'd do the house blessing so he's
doing the house blessing
and he puts the holy water on my face
but you know it's a little forceful
because they expect you to to have you
know the cultural competency that i did
not have they expected to know what to
do like you didn't know what to do yet i
had no i walked up to my mother i think
i was about 10 or 12 years old and i
said if that guy comes and throws water
on my face one more time i'm gonna beat
him up so you better warn him
you know and to go from that to you know
where i am now where i have that
that understanding
that that's a blessing
uh because again none of it was
explained it just like assumed that
everyone knows you know what's what's
going on and especially diaspora kids do
not always know
so one of the questions i have too is
for example in in the west and in the
the greek russian world you know the
eastern orthodox world are there we have
patreon saints right we so we have the
saints but the saints are also
end up being localized somehow but also
localized like parishes are named after
saints and and we have a sense in which
also people take on the names of saints
and and have their own kind of personal
patron saint so is that a tradition
which ethiopians also have
so um
one of the minor points of contention is
something that a lot of british writers
have written about and you know it's
it's really helpless but the the most
recent biology has shown that we are not
seban so they compared our dna to saudis
to yemeni to levantine to egyptians to
sudanese i mean they're really trying to
find the quote-unquote non-african
component everyone comes from africa but
you know all of eurasia left africa 60
000 years ago
so the quote-unquote non-african part of
ethiopians particularly the amhara
which is you know the ruling class for
this time period we're talking about
is found to be closest actually to the
minoan civilization
and to
tunisian jews
okay uh
and and so
um
that
that part of the biology
i think
goes to the hybridity that a lot of you
were talking about
and so
um
you know the patron saint culture in the
west or you know
in the east if we could call you the
east and us network
as you all joked about in the east and
the west versus the orient
is this predominantly i think more
individualized society and us being this
hybrid of you know
tunisian jew
minoan uh adjacent which is our eurasian
side has this individual component but
we also have our east african side which
is more communal and so the patron
saints are more regional than they are
individual i don't know if anyone who
really has an individual patron saint
and there's no real formal process
although some people
may do that but there are certain
institutions i would say the capital
city is a little different
but historic ethiopia in the in the
various regions would venerate the saint
that's from their region right
up in their region you mentioned
who's the saint who let the bird drink
out of his eye
he's considered an egyptian but he is uh
particularly
for example not venerated
in this region called wedjam because in
his
story it is said that the evil eye was
found there so those people don't like
to have him as a patron saint whether
you're an individual there from not
um
who's the one with wings that he meant
like the seraph
he is from a region called shoah and so
while he is because of other political
reasons also venerated in egypt and in
eritrea and other places the the main
place where he's venerated is a region
called shoah which is where he's from
another saint whom you mentioned one of
the nine greco-syrian or so-called roman
you know eastern roman rumi saints uh
he
was you know greco-roman you know like
but his where he landed is modern
tiguarai and so the region of tigrai and
parts of eritrea modern eritrea is where
he's venerated the most so it's super
regional in addition to that like i said
if you live in the capital city maybe
your patron saint is whatever church
parish you grew up at where the capital
city would be different than the other
historic regions
another thing we have i don't know if
you have this tradition it's called the
sawamaibar which is the cup fellowship
so people will choose you guys joked
about uh you know how we uh a medieval
emperor introduced monthly holidays and
additional to the biannual ones so these
cup fellowships will meet every month
for the holiday of whatever saint they
choose and it's up to this group to
decide it could be two people it could
be 15 people could be 30 people and what
they do is they feed the poor in the
name of the saint and then they feed
themselves and they they act as a sort
of mutual aid program as well for each
other if there's a wedding or a
graduation or a funeral they cover each
other's expenses as well all in the name
of this saint and so in that sense it's
like a
a regional patron saint and then these
small cup fellowship patron saints but
other than that there's no real
individual patron saints in this yeah
but the way you describe it it seems
like it's very embodied like especially
in these cup fellowships where people
will actually kind of let's say see
themselves as a communion of love where
they help each other and they kind of
support each other and in the under the
guides of a particular saint obviously
ultimately under the guise of christ but
kind of through the patronage of a
particular saint so i mean that's very
interesting because it sounds like it's
also a kind of social
net like a kind of social net to help to
help uh palliate for for tragedy and for
suffering i gave you the idealized
version
you know sometimes that the institution
breaks down sometimes and there's only a
social event you know but but when it is
good you know it's it's a charitable
organization that also takes care of the
people within and with and without
interesting
definitely and so
one of the things we didn't talk about
but i wanted you to maybe explain a
little bit or uh
talk more about is that for example it
seems like we have christmas right we
have the defeat the nativity uh but it
seems my perception is that that
ethiopian christians they have uh they
have tim cat they have the the
the feast of the of the the baptism of
christ but you don't so much have a
feast of nativity or do you have the
thesis oh we have the feast of nativity
okay huge all right
particularly in an area called lalibella
where the monolithic churches are i
don't know if you had a chance yes yeah
of course i went to la bella yeah that
that is christmas and they say christmas
in nalib allah
okay so nativity there and then you go
to epiphany or theophany or in in gander
yeah yeah well that's where they have
the big huge pool in gondor right where
everybody jumps in and and then aside
for my tolkien fans in the audience i i
still stipulate although i think people
will contradict me that i think both
roja and gwandar were named after
tolkien's knowledge of ethiopia because
there's a city called roja
which is the old name of lalibella
before it was named
really and then you have the city of
gwanda and these are the two cities that
we're talking about and those are the
two human city-states and love the rings
right those well those are real places
in ethiopia and i think that's too much
of a coincidence yeah well for sure for
sure gondor i remember hearing when i
saw the name i thought well this is way
too close he's way too close to lord of
the rings there's there's gotta be some
kind of alibaba
interesting so there is so so people
celebrate nativity in people celebrate
nativity and typically nativity is uh
that period each season of the calendar
has its own name that that period is
called stereo
which means the era of revelation or or
being made clear or manifestation and so
christmas is usually thought of as being
celebrated with epiphany slash theophany
at the baptism of christ and that that
whole season is considered one season
and people are uh the hymnography of the
church is is the same you sing baptism
and christmas songs like every day
throughout that i don't know the exact
period it's like two weeks or or
something and of course there's a
there's a fast right before christmas
yeah and there's a one-day fast uh that
that's like a 30 40 day fast it's called
the fast of the prophets and then
there's like a one day fast usually in
the middle of epiphany theophany
celebration
and there's a monthly merry holiday
during that time too and they call it
like the manifestation mary holiday and
then people usually think it has to do
with the manifestation of mary but no
it's actually manifestation of christ
but it's the merry holiday that lands
within that period of the church cycle
yeah that's symbolism i think it's still
there we still have it in in our
churches but it seems like it's very
strong in in your tradition the idea of
understanding the incarnation and also
the baptism in all this imagery of light
right as this kind of shining forth of
the revelation of christ you know and
and so i think that that's just it's a
very powerful symbolism especially for
people today as we
we kind of
we come back to the story of christ and
the way that i'm trying to help people
understand it that it's the pattern of
reality right it's not just it's just a
story and so the idea of the incarnation
is being this light which actually
shines
upon creation and helps us see it in its
proper form it helps us see you know
what everything is kind of moving
towards what the what the what the
reason for all of this is ultimately
something great to your tradition
there's something called
which is the hidden teaching and it's
it's one of these extra biblical
writings which are performed you know
there's a
interpretation of it but then there's
also the text itself and a friend of
mine who studied it intensely has told
me it's it's closest in the in the greek
orthodox communion to the mystagogy and
that's one of the things said both at
christmas and
at the baptism of christ or theophany
okay interesting so it's called the
hidden teaching basically yeah it's
called the hidden teaching uh that's
that's the name for it uh but it's
related to
uh the mystagonji in the greek yeah yeah
well i mean you see these the mystic
ideas you'll also see them different
mystic ideas as exactly kind of
revealing
the secret of what christ
is basically you know it's almost as if
now for us it's become so tame to say
something like he's god incarnate like
as if that's not a big deal so it's not
the most crazy the craziest thing you've
ever heard especially that he dies on a
cross right it's like all these things
are so are so uh mysterious that that
they're to remember how even in in the
early centuries they almost had to
whisper it or they had to wait until
people were baptized before they
revealed like the fact that we're eating
his flesh and blood like you know it was
very it's almost like you can't just say
this out loud or else you know they're
going to kill you
the catechumens must depart exactly the
catechin is about the port depart
so one of the big questions i have is is
the man like is the kind of mystery of
lalibella and so for people who don't
know lalibella is you've seen everybody
seen pictures of them but these rock dog
churches that are kind of networked
together uh in the city of lalibella um
and so
how do you what is the function of
lalibela let's say
theologically historically what is it
what is the functions of it well i first
because of the history channel have to
say it's not aliens i have to first say
that
that greek guy he's and the fact that
he's greek i'm like come on man you got
orthodox in your family at least you
should know he attributes it to aliens
what do you agree with lali bella the
aliens yes okay yeah on the history
channel okay of all places yeah man um
because it couldn't be angels and humans
in collaboration um which is what the
ethiopian story is
which is much more beautiful yeah and
the story of lalabella goes back to what
i was saying earlier about people who
nick pitt at the nitpick at the 3000
year history of ethiopia so there's a
clear start of a specific dynasty in
1270 a.d and the dispute is whether that
is a restoration or something totally
new
and the reason why that dispute exists
in the first place is because aksum as
we know it
at the the great ancient civilization
runs from about 180 to 380 pagan
and then 300 a.d
to
about 900 a.d as an orthodox christian
kingdom and that regime falls
and is replaced by something called the
zagwe dynasty and the typical zagway
story is that they are descendants of
the ministers of the queen of uh of of
queen of sheba who intermingled with the
ministers of king solomon so not
directly of solomon and sheba but of the
ministers and all those people and so
that regime lasted about 200 300 years
from around 980 to 1270 aad when it fell
and that was the kind of interlude and
then whether aksum and 1270 are
connected that's for different people to
have their opinions on that people say
that in 1270 it was a restoration of
solomonic dynasty that happened
basically that's the song
that's that's the tradition and part of
the historical
tension is that pretty much all the
information we have is from that
solomonic dynasty yeah so people say
it's biased it's yeah that it is
condensed
and i have my good friend who knows
about the hidden teaching he's a big fan
of that that zagwe dynasty that that
intermediary 300 years it's kind of um
there's a very specific the ethiopian
church is an amalgamation of three
things
of antioch of alexandria and of itself
of axon
and
we always have the aksum element but the
coptic element sometimes when people
paint the story it's like oh we were
coptic till the 1950s they don't realize
that that coptic connection was very
feeble and there's little historic
evidence for it for sometimes like a
thousand years you know sometimes they
are said to have said a muslim to be our
archbishop really
yeah sometimes it goes 23 years 100
years without sending a bishop and
people are like well what happened in
those intermediary years well what
happened is antioch is still right there
and there are some stories sometimes in
the 1200s sometimes in 10 uh like a
thousand a.d where sometimes they say at
one moment there were a hundred syrian
bishops and it's like why were there a
hundred syrian bishops what were they
doing there you know what was uh going
on my friend also believes that
sometimes the the arcmand rights
that people describe as archemandrites
may have acted as sort of indigenous
bishops in these intermediate years
there's a lot of
lack of clarity but anyway all this is
context for lalibela or roha
in in which case that period
uh including lalibela who's a king are a
series of like four or five priest kings
and so they're both priests in the
ethiopian orthodox church and they're
also kings and emperors of all of
ethiopia so when is this again
between 900 and 1270.
okay so that's i'm sorry to say but
that's do you know the legend of
professor john do you know about yes
that sounds exactly like that's just
what it is that's like they're that's
why oh my goodness yeah that's and
that's what they were that's what they
were
and and you know most kings
grew up in monasteries
uh to hide them so that they don't get
slaughtered as potential claimants to
the throne but you know at their some of
them leave when they're eight some leave
when they're 15. there are various
accounts i i spoke recently
about um emperor teodros was one of
emperor theodore one of the famous very
famous uh
uniting ethiopian kings of the 1800s and
one of the most pivotal moments in his
life is he was raised in a monastery and
at one point he's like 12 or 15 i forget
his exact age marauders come and
slaughter everyone in the monastery and
this is like this is not a hagiography
this is the guy's chronicle and he's the
sole survivor oh my goodness and and so
he became a little bit of a political
realist after that he still you know had
the the lord's name on his lips but you
know some of his actions people
thought of him as a brutal guy but he's
a little traumatized slightly
traumatized ptsd uh yeah
imagine you live in a monastery and that
that happens to you but so anyway king
lalibella at this time i think
it also kind of coincides with the rise
of islam and
uh
at various points ethiopia controls kind
of modern-day yemen parts of india and
that whole red sea route through which
we saw in the past year in in modern
times
that uh you know if the suez canal is
blocked people got to go all the way
around africa and you have to realize
ethiopia ruled that controlled that that
that seaway and so that 900 to 1200 is
the receding period where the empire
contracts and it's more local and so the
trade routes we had been pilgrimaging
since early on i don't know 4th century
5th century to jerusalem yeah some
people say that the armenian alphabet
was made by an armenian monk
or priest who met up with an ethiopian
one in jerusalem and
used because they have an indo-european
language of its own branch it they used
the the script from the ethiopians but
they had totally different sounds really
i'd never heard that before so they
would think that
like the guest script is what influenced
armenian script absolutely and look at
the armenian script and look at the
ethiopians and now that you say it now
that you say it i'm like
i mean not an expert but now that you
say it i'm like
they're a lot like that than ours
yeah and armenia is in our communion as
well so these trade routes to jerusalem
which had been around for centuries get
blocked because of the rise of islam and
the changing geopolitics and so
king lalibella uh it was also a priest
father as well and a saint in the church
he decides to create a new jerusalem
which is not to be confused you know the
heavenly jerusalem but a new kind of
physical
jerusalem in ethiopia so that people
don't have the pilgrimage to jerusalem
anymore because those trade routes were
cut off due to geopolitics and so that's
what that whole
lalibela enterprise of the series the
main church is georges or george and st
george and then there are several other
churches around it built out of that
that monolithic structure
and so
yeah
so the idea would be that it's like it's
is it but does it map on to jerusalem
like is is there some people tried to
kind of find analogies between the
actual city of jerusalem and and
you'll find like engravings of the star
of david and uh for for that matter uh
imagery that later gets associated with
a particular german regime but that also
has a much more ancient symbol uh we
won't get the yeah and when
i saw the craziest things i've ever seen
which is
crusader crosses and like you said you
see stars of david with crosses in them
and and like and so that's i mean it's
you feel like you're looking at this
puzzle that you can't completely
understand because
you know some of those crosses
definitely look like hospital hospital
or hospital hospital or crosses and so i
was like man there were people crossed a
lot of people came through here and the
you know the the crossing of influences
and the the discussions must have been
pretty pretty vivid
yeah it's a it's a
what people don't understand about the
empire is the way in which
it was extremely exclusive but also
inclusive and you and richard talked
about the biblical canon and how open it
is and people got to know you know it's
it's the west that has a closed cannon
the greek communion and our communion
the aphrodite communion have technically
opened canons so at any moment the holy
synods could decide to add books to the
bible and you know that's that's their
right you know that's their apostolic
right uh but in any event you know we
just got books and writings from
everywhere one of the things from our
monastic tradition which i always point
out to people is that we have um
uh aragawi manfasawi who's a different
aragawi the spiritual elder who i think
his name is john sabah and then we also
have marisak who's isaac the syrian yeah
and these are two of the three this is
two-thirds of what we call the book of
monks that every monk is supposed to
read in our tradition
and they're
post calcidonian
members of the church of the east which
only affirms the first two councils and
i know isaac the syrian is venerated in
your tradition as well and i i often
point to that as like it's not even like
one book it's it's it's it's the
majority of the monastic tradition the
texts they have to read are from the
church of the east yeah and you also
talked about um
this liturgical rite that includes on
good friday
the thief on the right well we have that
as well and we actually have the
expanded version there's a whole play
i've seen on youtube of the syriac
version which is like 15 minutes our
version is like an hour and it's it's
really hilarious you know the cherub
berates the thief is like you're
unworthy you're wicked you know you're
ugly you know who are you to come here
before that and all the but eventually
you know he lets it he gets in
wait so these are like these are what
like kind of liturgical plays or kind of
yes it's a literature so that one the
thief or the outlaw on the right that's
performed
by the clergy on good friday um but the
the monastic books are just sort of
writings that are supposed to be studied
by all monks and so we have john saba
the spiritual elder and we also have
isaac the syrian yeah because isaac the
syrian how can anybody deny it like he
he's so amazing like what he says is
such pure gold that
that's why i feel like even if even even
if for us like in maybe in practice he
was supposedly a heretic it's like he
says nothing heretical that and and he's
so inspired that i i think it
it just kind of uh how can i say it it
soothes over whatever whatever uh
distinctions existed you know absolutely
and i'll point if there are people you
know who are in your audience in your
tradition i point you to the book on
isaac the syrian by metropolitan
hilarion which is a fantastic book and
it
it it talks about how him
uh along with one of the gregory's i
always get them confused you know they
get into this you know that all should
be saved that and that is considered
officially in the orthodox church a
heresy and and he but he explains why
he's
thinking in that way and that minor
thing doesn't take away all of the great
spiritual advice on silence on how to
read the psalms one of the pieces of
advice he gives is that the way you
should pray is you begin by reading the
psalms and you don't say oh i'm going to
do a chapter a day or a million
chapters a day you just begin reading
and then when your body collapses that's
when you stop you know and that's what
he says if that's if for you if that's a
sentence good that's that's your
two-year spiritual benefit but if it's
three chapters for you then so be it and
if you do the psalter all night also so
be it
that's amazing yeah for sure for sure
some amazing things
so people so do people still see
lalibela as a kind of pilgrimage place
absolutely okay absolutely as i said
earlier christmas is the largest one
celebrated there but pasca is also big
in la balla
interesting
so we want to go there for any holiday i
mean yeah exactly the amount of learned
people in that area is ridiculous like
the ratio of learned scholars
i mean in the diaspora we have to beg
for you know one or two learned scholars
per church but there you know you see
like hundreds of clergy you know people
what people don't understand is the
large churches i said there were small
medium and large churches in ethiopia
especially in the capital city because
that's where you can make some money on
a more cynical note but the large
churches in ethiopia would have 300
clergy trained
i mean it think about what a service is
like when there are 300 you know and
sometimes they have shifts so they're
working at at different times the
administrator the hyrule monk at my
church he always tells me funny stories
and he told me
there's a
a tradition of saint jared or saint
jared
and it's a book called a part of the
prayer of his books called zayinankis
which means
god's reign or god is king
and so
when your parish gets big enough you can
hire a zainagus
chanter
so the job of this zayina gist chanter
is between the hours of 3 a.m and maybe
4 30 a.m every day
whether there are a thousand
parishioners or whether no parishioners
arrive is to pray and chant this prayer
and so all the large churches have this
guy where you can go any day of the week
the church is always open and you go in
at 3am
and there's somebody there
exactly and the idea is to you know
um ethiopia unlike other members of our
communion
was never fully conquered you know we
could say we conquered ourselves
internally but we were never fully
conquered by another outside force yeah
so our christianity was not a
christianity in hiding it was a
christianity if if anything with too
much prosperous ease which is time to
really develop these traditions and so
these large parishes try to resemble the
angels and to try to keep the watch so
that at every hour of the day
there is some sort of prayer going on
and with a few meal breaks that that's
very true especially if you go to the
monasteries i imagine if if if they're
doing that 3 a.m prayer in just like a
regular town church i mean the
monasteries must be completely insane
one of the things that really
distinguishes also ethiopian
christianity from from let's say the
greek russian communion is
the drums
and the rhythm
and so i'm curious to know how like at
least what are the traditions about that
because i mean do people see it as
coming from all the way from solomon or
is there other traditions about the use
of the drums and the rhythmic
instruments
it's a very great question and this goes
to the african side of our hybridity we
are
uh i mean the cops can argue a little
bit but nobody can argue like us that we
are the the african orthodox church and
so you better know we're going to have
some drums but yes they have an asterisk
next to it
and the asterisk is that
they certainly seem very ancient
and again it depends if you want to go
with the mainline narrative of the
church or go to what the historical
evidence says the main line of the
church yeah will tie it back all the way
to the time of judaism the the people
searching for more and more evidence
don't really see evidence of the drums
before medieval times and that doesn't
mean that they weren't there
but it does mean that the tradition was
less elaborate before there and we're
still searching for evidence so
there is um i believe it was
father mandorff um was a professor of of
a friend of mine
who went to saint vlads and he told this
story which i will tell again
that you know in your communion the
liturgy has this balance between
byzantium right and the palestinian
right and the byzantian right kind of
baptized or christianized what was the
pagan theater before and so the
elaborate elements come from that
whereas the more monastic tradition of
palestine was more interested in kind of
a simple psalter and and maybe a
somebody plus that but not much more and
we see the same thing within ethiopia so
one of the extra liturgical or
non-eucharistic liturgical schools is
called aqua
and the aquaculum tradition is where the
drum is beat that's where all the drum
beating comes from uh historically in
ethiopia that has centuries of evidence
and then you have a more minor modern
amharic tradition which is established
from about the 70s till now okay
we and we could talk about that but
there's this whole so you're saying it
developed in a particular place within
ethiopia like it wasn't something that
was universal before it was it was not
i'll tell you
my grandfather and a lot of his
ancestors are buried at a monastery
called walterba which is in the middle
of the land of which the civil war is
going on right now
and waldeba is southwest of aksum but
northwest of gundar so it's kind of the
halfway point between the city of
guandar and the city of aksum which were
two major cities yeah a long time and
two former capitals of the empire so
while deba is square in the middle of
that it's a fifth century monastery and
they view the drum as worldly all right
okay so
the drum is forbidden
at that monastery and that monastery
doesn't even acknowledge that whole aqua
tradition which is this drum beating and
elaborate uh swinging of the staff as
well yeah the staff yeah they don't
acknow they use the staff just to hold
themselves up and they only believe in
acapella worship similar to the rest of
the orthodox church and they do the main
eucharistic liturgy and they do the
liturgy of the hours so what mind
boggles many ethiopian christians which
many even i would say ethiopian deacons
don't know if they don't know the
tradition writ large
is that
if you go on pasca the feast of feasts
expecting like the craziest drums if you
go to that monastery you're not going to
get that what you're going to get is the
liturgy of the hours followed by the
eucharistic liturgy and that's the same
thing that they do every day of the year
oh okay so they don't they don't even
have kind of festival liturgies and they
yeah interesting i mean that could be
like the monastic like just like all
these monks even in in the our tradition
there are these stories of these monks
that wouldn't chant melodies like they
thought melodies were worldly so they
were just basically doing monotone just
so there wouldn't be any variation in
their in their chanting you know no well
these ones will definitely not be
monotone they'll sing but they only will
sing the acapella things right yeah uh
they have this view
for example my bishop who i mentioned
earlier he used to love hitting the drum
when he was a monk and that's rare for
monks
bishops are forbidden from hitting it
standing up they can sit down
and they could hit it during the slow
part but any sort of fast melody while
they're standing the bishops are
forbidden and he's antsy because if it
were just up to him
he would love to still hit it but it
would scandalize the entire church for
him to hit the drum that's amazing which
is itself a holy instrument used to
praise god but it's just it's seen as
kind of beneath the position of of a
bishop
and it's rare among monks it's usually a
married priest or deacons or now also
choir members who could be men or women
and just would hit the drum well when i
was in aksum i i had a very strange
meeting where i met three scholars from
tel aviv three jewish scholars from tel
aviv um and all three of them were kind
of experts on ethiopia especially
experts on ethiopia trying to find the
jewish connection like trying to see you
know how how close a jewish connection
is and one of these scholars told me
that
in ethiopia they use what's called a
system right which is a a staff and and
it has like a
it's hard to explain it has i mean i'll
post a picture of it it has these little
metal uh parts inside that move and so
you shake it and it sinks right it sinks
like uh
and he said that systems were common in
ancient worship they even they exist in
egypt they exist in all these ancient
cultures in the menomination as well oh
okay so what they're described in
scripture
in the bible it talks about systems in
the psalms like part of the instruments
that were used and he said right now he
said in ethiopia is the only place in
the entire world
where they still use this instrument
and for him it was like a connection
frame was like a way to connect ethiopia
to kind of ancient hebrew worship
because he said it
it's the they still have this tradition
from like thousands of years ago and and
they need it needs to be almost like a
continuous tradition because you you
just saw it just
named in the scripture you wouldn't know
what it was unless you had actually had
one in your hand and seen what it looks
like and used it so there has to be this
kind of continual uh physical
transmission of the instrument for you
to get to now and still go to church and
see people chinking this instrument i'll
tell you a funny story i have
a lot of secular family and
we were at a secular christmas
celebration which is funny enough
and they had a system in their house
and we're playing charades
and so my family members you know my
parents age and they know what it is but
their child has no idea what it is
so i wrote it in amharic which is
is called
or in english the system and plural
systra like any sort of latin plural
and i wrote it in english and amharic
and that poor boy my little cousin
worked his best to try to charade what
it was he had no idea what it was and
when they saw what i wrote they said how
mean and unfair are you and i said look
you have this object in your house
you're venerating it by by having it
there as a cultural prop so we're gonna
we're gonna use it but yeah it's a
general eastern mediterranean thing so
it includes the jewish culture like you
said pharaonic egypt and the minoan
civilization if you look at the the
remains of their their artwork which is
uh from the island of crete the the
that was there before you know it was uh
the during the bronze age before that
bronze collapse so
um
all of those civilizations had this very
ancient instrument yeah and that is part
of the the
school which is it accompanies the drum
it's never by itself it's always
accompanying the drum and it also is
related that tradition has blended in
with the poetry tradition so it's used
with the poetry as well what the drum
and the system are never used for and i
always have to make this explicit and
this is every ethiopian church is that
the eucharistic liturgy is totally
acapella
this is for post-liturgical celebrations
like hymns that are done or
pre-eucharistic liturgical hymns and
just
use the word kidan when you're talking
about the hagiographies the full term is
kalkidan which means promise or covenant
so there's the
kidan which is the prayer of the
covenant which begins the eucharistic
liturgy and in the eucharistic liturgy
there are i think three to four i think
four places where a bell is rung to
signify different things when hallelujah
or hallelujah is said to begin the
liturgy a bell is wrong
when uh the lord have mercies are said a
bell is wrong when the communion
descends uh a bell is wrong
and when the catechumens are told to
depart that's not in order saying it off
memory but at those four points
catechum uh beginning of the liturgy
uh catechumen departure which is the
halfway point when after the gospel is
read
the uh sayings of the lord have mercy
and the descent of the communion and
those four points a bell is wrong
everything else in the eucharistic
liturgy is purely acapella
mouth alone is the instrument but before
that period in a in a certain specific
time and after that period you're
allowed to bring out the system and
you're allowed to bring out the cabaret
or the drum and you're allowed to use
that to make music but again it's not
compulsory and some of the monastics
don't like doing that yeah yeah
so we've been talking for a while so i'd
have one last big question for you i
guess and then and then we'll call it
we'll call it good although i i could
talk about this forever like i could
just keep going i know but i don't want
i don't want to abuse people's like
attention as well um
so
in in the in our podcast one of the
things we presented was this this uh
byzantine tradition actually syrian
tradition but but accepted by the
byzantines of the the apocalypse of
pseudomethodius right and so and in this
tradition you have this idea
uh and it's present in other byzantine
traditions as well the meeting of
alexander in ethiopia right the the the
idea even that that alexander's mother
uh was ethiopian and then the idea that
the roman emperor
will
hide in the in ethiopia right i don't
know if you follow that story so the
idea that i did that the last roman
emperor will hide in ethiopia whatever
that means and that at the end of times
will kind of rise out of ethiopia and
that will be like ethiopia stretching
your hands out unto the lord and that
will kind of signify the
basically the end of the world is what
what it seems to be and so i don't know
if there is something i like i don't
know if there is are some traditions
which are akin to that in ethiopia or or
at least like what you thought when you
when you heard that that that
description
i had never heard a tradition like that
in ethiopia that doesn't mean it
doesn't exist i just haven't heard that
i think it's in um
matthew 12 right that the queen of the
south will arise in condemnation of this
generation that that's prophetic
language from the bible as well yeah um
i have always heard
this
in politics who is the successor of rome
because i'm interested in in the study
of empire and you see you know nobody in
byzantium called it byzantium they
thought of themselves as rome even
though they were conquered by rome and
became romans they were the eastern part
of the roman empire so you see the
geographic rome shifts from rome itself
to byzantium which thought of itself as
rome yeah and a lot of people nowadays
ask like who's the successor and there
are some people who look at the current
modern russian state that has exited
communism and is got some sort of
amalgamation of of different ideas of
when to intervene when to not and you
know that that military cathedral that
they built has this archaeo futuristic
vibe to it where it's like super you
know powerful
representation of the state but also of
the orthodox church a patriarch kirill
has also commented a lot on ethiopian
situations and oh really yeah oh yeah
he's supporting the current ethiopian
regime
which ousted during the the reign of
donald trump it ousted
this regime that was backed by the us
for a long time and donald trump you
know love him or hate him his
nonchalance towards ethiopia
allowed ethiopia to kind of rule itself
instead of being guided by the the
global american
empire and and so a lot of people think
that russia will be this prophetic you
know russia is the successor state to
rome for many reasons because of the
connections with byzantium which
connected to the original rome but as
you said
it may be that from the extremities of
the world from the ends of the world
the queen of the south may rise again
and there are many people i am myself an
ethiopian restorationist and there are
many
others who are
uh elite in the diaspora i always
noticed a lot of the people involved
with the beginnings of saint vladimir's
were some of the people tied to the
russian elites who were expelled out of
the country yeah and i think not enough
people realized that and the same thing
has happened with the ethiopian
situation and i'm hopeful something like
that for happened i don't know if that's
going to bring about judgment day only
the lord knows when that time will be
but i do like you
and like richard uh would say that
perhaps ethiopia i'll say it that way
perhaps
ethiopia has a role to play
yeah that's for sure i'm i'm sure that
ethiopia has the role to play but i i i
think that
we're all kind of fascinated to see what
what what that is and kind of
i mean i think that's been a fascination
for mine forever and you know my
intuition which i now see is just not an
intuition at all you know i since we did
the podcast i've had several people
write me because i said things like
ethiopia doesn't just have the ark
ethiopia is the ark and i've had ethio
now i've had ethiopians write me and say
yeah that's what everybody thinks like
you're not coming into some great enzo
they didn't say it that way but they're
basically saying that all ethiopians
think that ethiopia is the ark and i'm
like okay yeah well well yeah you have
to you have to be careful we we
ethiopians can buy i don't know how the
greeks and the armenians are maybe us
three can compete to who has the most
hubris and love uh the whole country and
patriotism but yeah they're pretty up
there if you say nice things about
ethiopia we love
there you go well i'm happy to know that
i'm loved by some ethiopians i'm sure
that'll be that'll be something that
will that would be very useful to me one
day i'm pretty sure and so this has been
really wonderful i really enjoyed it and
i feel like it could go on forever so
what i'm going to do is we're going to
put this out and we're going to see the
comments we're going to see what people
say see what people ask and if you have
questions if you have things because
there are so many roads we could have
gone uh write it down in the comments
and uh and who knows well maybe we'll
just do a second part and go into what
people want to hear about so thank you
for your time
thank you for having me